JUSTINE DUPONT (VOICEOVER):
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
FRED DAVID: Four years
ago, we moved to Nazaré.
And we decided to focus
on big wave surfing.
Every big wave is different.
But I think Nazaré is probably
the best place to learn
how to deal with big waves.
MAN: For me, surfing big
waves is totally terrifying.
So much of the training is about
how to survive, how not to die.
You have to have an
incredibly strong
mind and body to face
off with these 50 or 60
or 70 foot waves.
When the lip of
the wave crashes,
it can feel like a ton of bricks
smashing you into concrete.
That's the impact zone.
Once you're trapped there, it's
nearly impossible to get out.
You have to find your way to
the surface between the waves
and get a jet ski
driver to pick you up.
FRED DAVID (VOICEOVER): Our
work is really dangerous.
My goal is first to have
Justine safe, second,
to find the best way for her.
JUSTINE DUPONT:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
FRED DAVID: In Nazaré, she
was surfing, like, every
swell every day, all day long.
And she never fell.
So when we got the
call for Hawaii
for the [INAUDIBLE] contest,
she was, like, super confident.
She was, OK, I'm ready.
[CHATTER]
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]